this video has gone viral
pretty
uh disturbing and and uh kind of
certainly shocking uh ktnv in Las Vegas
uh has a story Channel 13 has obtained
video of a Clark County District Court
Judge being violently attacked by a man
during a hearing on Wednesday morning
the man involved in the attack
is it looks like his name is
Deborah
um de obra Deo
BR but you got to you got to you give
birth to a son you name him
Deborah it's probably not de it's
probably de obra or something like that
but it's too close to Deborah
anyway the man I mean this that's really
not the point at all uh the man involved
in the attack is Deborah delone readen
who is being sentenced for aggravated
battery with substantial bodily harm
prior to the attack on Judge Mary K hus
he entered a guilty play in a previous
hearing
uh the video shows judge hus denying
Reen's request for probation due to his
criminal history and preparing to
sentence him to jail
time so um this is a very interesting
case because of along with being
disturbing you know
it we as we have talked about plenty on
this show we have a real serious crisis
in this country of violent criminals
being released from jail given probation
uh allowed out on bail paroled whatever
the case may be you know they they are
allowed to avoid jail time or they're
released from
jail um even though they are still
violent criminals like they are violent
people and so in this case you had at
least one judge in Las Vegas who said no
you know
what that you committed a violent crime
We're Not Just Gonna Let You Go free you
have to you have to go to
jail and um
right in that moment this guy this
criminal decided to to prove exactly why
that judge was corrected making that
decision let's watch the tape I
appreciate that but I think it's time
that he gets a taste of something else
because I just can't with that history
in accordance with the laws of State
NADA this
court
with
you hey get off her get off her you're
good you're good stop don't do
thisy is she
okay so apparently the judge uh from
what I understand the judge was
basically uninjured thank God in the
attack uh somebody that was another
injury though someone else was injured
um somehow the guy now I mean
personally I they spent and that video
goes on I mean they spent at least a
minute that they spent at least like a
full 60 seconds trying to pry this guy
off of the judge in the courtroom that
he was
assaulting you know one question I have
is like why why does he get 60 seconds
I'd give him like zero second I mean
from the time when the assault
happens to when you pull your gun there
should be like one second to the lapses
now it might be the case that uh they
weren't able to to do that because if
they had done that depending on what was
happen happening maybe the judge you
know you'd end up uh harming the judge
in the process so that might be
why
but if there's ever a time to use lethal
Force it's when someone is physically
assaulting a judge in a
courtroom there are many other times to
use it too but that's should be one of
them if you're single you've probably
seen or heard about all the insane
dating apps out there but what if I told
you there was actually a dating app that
cared about your morals and biblical
values higher bond is a new Christian
dating app built to be safer less
stressful and more Christ centered
higher bond is completely different than
anything else out there there's no
addictive swiping the focus is truly on
quality over quantity and it's designed
to form lasting marriages Mar uh higher
bond is veteran owned by a husband and
wife looking to change the way Christian
singles meet online it's no secret that
left-wing media and big Tech are against
companies like higher bond in fact one
of the major um tech companies is
preventing higher bond from running ads
on the platform are Society in our
country need what higher bond is
providing more than ever so what are you
waiting for sign up today for free at
higher bond.com make 2024 Special by
meeting someone new with higher bond.com
that's higher bond.com
today and now uh the articles about this
attack all mention that this guy is
expected to face additional charges well
yeah i' certainly hope
so and the additional sentence like he
should go to jail for a 100 years now
they should pass down a sentence of a
hundred years in prison which obviously
means you're going to die in
prison because this is you cannot allow
this I mean for all all we hear about
protecting the Integrity of our system
and all the rest of
it uh you need to make an example of
this guy so he was upset because he was
it probably would have been a relatively
small amount of jail time given the
charges now you come back and you bring
him in in Chains this time you bring him
in Chained and you say hey guess what
scumbag now you going to jail for 100
years good job your life's
over your life's over because we don't
you know Society we don't need you
you'll never be in society again you're
going to suffer in a cage for the rest
of your life
congratulations that's what should
happen if you're serious about defending
the Integrity of our justice system what
little of it is
left if you want to see a lot more this
kind of thing then come back with an
additional charge and put him in jail
for like a year because of it if you
want to see more of
this um but again I mean this this is
exactly why you know she she
unfortunately was made to pay a price
for it but
this this proves exactly why this judge
made the right decision you can hear
what you said prior to uh passing down
the sentence she said no you know this
based on the charges you get you need a
taste I think she said you need a taste
of something else you need a taste of
justice is what you
need
um and prior to that this guy was making
uh he was giving the normal Saab
story well never do it again I'm a CH
have changed my ways your honor I'm a
different
person you see I I've I've I've I'll
never I'm I'm I'll never do it again I'm
I've been
reformed and how many times do judges
get this sub story and for whatever
reason they believe
it and they send the person back out on
the street until something heinous
happens and this guy this guy switches
in like 30 seconds from I've changed my
ways to leaping over the judge's bench
and assaulting the judge in the
courtroom tells you everything he needs
to know thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast